In the last video, we tried to
relate what 13.7 billion years
really means by compressing
it to 10 years, which is still
a pretty long time, at
least from our perspective.
And we saw that these huge
periods of time, everything
that's happened since
the United States
Declaration of
Independence, all gets
compressed into
just five seconds.
And that's not much when
you think about 10 years.
I mean 10 years, you
could wait around a lot.
That's a huge amount of time.
So hopefully, that put things
in perspective a little bit.
What I want to do in this video
is kind of do the same thing,
but relate the 13.7
billion years, if that were
a distance or the
length of a time line,
how big each of these
periods would be.
So just to start off,
at the timeline--
I'm recording this in
high definition right now.
There should be
1,280 pixels wide,
depending on where
you're watching it.
So maybe you're watching
it on a high def TV.
If the timeline was
width of my screen right
over here, if the timeline was
the width of my screen here,
so if that was
13.7 billion years,
from there-- let's say this is
the beginning of the universe
and this is our present time.
If that was 13.7 billion
years, the amount
of time that humans have been
on this planet-- modern humans,
so people who look and think
like us-- the amount of time
that we have been on this
planet will not even be a pixel.
This little dot I drew
is multiple pixels.
The amount of time we've been
here would not even be a pixel.
In fact, a pixel--
and that dot I
drew here is about four pixels.
But a pixel, just one
little pixel on my screen,
would represent
11 million years.
Let me scroll over it.
It would represent
11 million years.
So if this was the
timeline, the dinosaurs
would have been extinct about
six pixels from the end.
So it would be right about--
so six pixels from the end
is when the dinosaurs
would have gotten extinct.
And the amount of time that
modern humans are on the planet
wouldn't even register here.
It would be 1/20 of
that pixel over there.
In fact, if we just expanded
that very last pixel--
if we were to expand
I'll do it in yellow-- that very
last tiny pixel that you can't
see, if we were expand
that to the entire length
of this screen again-- so
if we were to just expand
just that very last pixel--
so I'm saying everything
on this yellow line could be
contained in that very last dot
right over there, then
every pixel in this
would still be 8,000 years.
So the entire period
of time that humanity
has been on this
planet on this scale--
so we've broken out this
little tiny pixel here all
the way out here, 200,000 years,
that's on the order of about 25
of these pixels.
So 25 of these pixels would
be something like that,
not even that, not even that.
So 25 pixels on this screen--
at least at my resolution,
is about that distance.
So this is the fraction
of just that pixel that
is the amount of time humans
have been on the planet.
If you want the
time since Jesus,
it would be 1/4 of a pixel
on this yellow scale.
On this yellow scale, it
would be 1/4 of a pixel.
And the amount of time to the
Declaration of Independence
would be even a more
minuscule amount of time.
So that's one way
to think about it.
But these timelines to some
degree also don't give justice.
So another way to
think about it,
what if we had a time line
that stretched from here,
where I am, in this
San Francisco Bay
Area, if it stretched 1,300
kilometers to Seattle?
So if this thing
stretched 1,300 kilometers
all the way to Seattle, so
this thing, the Big Bang,
would be sitting in Seattle.
This would be
sitting in Seattle.
The universe--
well, the formation
of the Earth and the
solar system, this
would be about 200
kilometers away,
a little over 200 kilometers.
And in the direction of
Seattle, I don't know,
that would get us in
probably some part
of northern California
with redwoods and whatnot.
But just to give an
idea of 200 kilometers,
that would get me from where I
am near the coast of California
to about the Nevada border.
So still a pretty
good distance relative
to the entire timeline.
The dinosaurs, the
last land dinosaurs,
when the Earth got hit by an
asteroid this-- so remember,
our whole timeline now stretches
all the way to Seattle.
This event now would
have only occurred
about 3,000 meters away.
Or maybe I should just say
three kilometers away or roughly
about two miles.
So that's still seems like
a pretty good distance.
But remember, our timelines
stretches all the way
to Seattle from the
San Francisco area.
So it's a pretty big timeline.
So this is already a
pretty small distance.
But it gets even smaller.
Australopithecus,
this right over here,
when they were roaming the
Earth 3 million years ago,
this gets reduced
to a little bit more
than a football field, about
150 meters, not kilometers.
Let me write that in a color
where there's some contrast.
150 meters is
where-- so 150 meters
in the direction of
Seattle, if that's
the timeline that
we're talking about.
And then the first
humans, even shorter.
It's only going to be 10 meters,
10 meters of this timeline that
stretches all the
way to Seattle.
The birth of Jesus,
2,000 years ago,
would be 10 centimeters, 10
centimeters on a time line
that stretches from San
Francisco to Seattle.
And then finally, the
Declaration of Independence,
the American Declaration
of Independence,
would be 1 centimeter on a time
line that stretches to Seattle.
Anyway, I don't know
if that put things
in more or less perspective.
But it was worth
giving it a shot.